Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Kapagann. Ich bin hier auf dieser Station als Dienstabender tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir Bescheid sagen.
Ich muss vielleicht als erstes noch einmal fragen. Verraten Sie mir bitte noch einmal Ihren Namen?
Kapagann.
Herr Kapagann.
Ja.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheid sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar Argumente fragen.
Sie sind damit einfach standen?
Ja, sicher.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Udo Schlüter.
Udo Schmitter.
Schlüter.
S-T-H-L-U, also U, umlaut, T-E-R.
Okay, T-E-R.
Frau Schlüterl, können Sie Ihre Vorname stabilen?
U-D-O, ganz einfach.
Okay.
Wie Udo Lindt-Berch.
Herr Schlüterl, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Ja, 46 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 7.07.1976.
Ja.
Und wie viel schwer sind Sie?
Wie schwer?
Ja, so 86 kg wie ich.
Ja, gut.
Und wie viel groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 m.
Herr Schlüterl, was für eine Beschwerderhaut ist es?
Was für ein Stessow?
Ja, also ich habe Schmerzen im Bauch.
Und das wird in letzter Zeit immer schlimmer.
Und ich fühle mich auch total schlapp.
Ich kenne mich also selber nicht wieder.
Und die Schmerzen sind ziemlich unangenehm.
Ich merke aber auch, dass ich so schlapp bin.
Ich komme die Treppen kaum noch hoch.
Ja.
Ja, dann habe ich zugenommen in letzter Zeit.
Ich habe so einen dicken Bauch bekommen.
Und ja, manchmal ist mir extrem schlecht.
Manchmal nur ein bisschen.
Genau.
Dann habe ich also so ein komisches Kribbeln in den Beinen.
Das sind so ganz viele Sachen, die ich fühle.
Ja, wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Im Bauch haben Sie gesagt?
Obelbauch oder Unterbauch?
Eigentlich eher so im Oberbauch.
Obelbauch.
Rechts- oder links- oder grün-Bauer-Sagen?
Kann ich das sagen?
Vielleicht am ersten ein bisschen nach rechts verschoben.
Das ist der ganze Oberbauch.
Ja, Oberbauch-Schmerz.
Seit wann haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat langsam angefangen.
Das geht jetzt schon ein paar Monate.
Vielleicht ein Viertel Jahr.
Ja, ein paar Monate.
Drei Monate.
Genau.
Das ist ein dicker Bauch.
Ja, ich merke, dass meine Hosen knäfen.
Ja.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind die Schmerzen drückend oder steichend?
Oder dumpfer Schmerzen?
Also eher drückend als stechend.
Und ja, das ist ein drückender, dumpfer Schmerz.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala beschreiben?
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 sehr leichte und sehr starke Schmerzen meint.
Ja, vielleicht in der Mitte bei 5.
Ja.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder versteckt?
Weil die Schmerzen sind sehr leichte.
Ja, das ist ein sehr leckerer Schmerz.
Das ist ein sehr leckerer Schmerz.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn ich mich hinlege,
dann, wenn ich abends zu Ruhe komme,
habe ich das Gefühl, dass es schon ein bisschen besser wird.
Aber so ganz weg gehen, die eigentlich nicht.
Genau, wenn Sie hinlegen,
ist die Schmerzen besser geworden.
Ja, wenn ich halt Ruhe gebe,
wenn ich nicht rumlaufe und so.
Ja, und gibt es etwas, da es die oder gibt es eine bestimmte Ausdose für diese Schmerzen,
zum Beispiel nach dem fettiges Essen, sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden, oder?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht so aufgefallen. Also, was ich merke, dass eben so weit,
mal Belastung, wenn ich die Treppen hochgehe, dass ich dann so außer Puste bin und ich glaube,
dann werden die Schmerzen auch ein bisschen schlimmer.
Okay, Belastungs und wenn Sie Pusten auch, ja?
Ja, ich habe auch so ein bisschen trockenen Pusten, das stimmt ja.
Genau, ja, okay. Sie haben trockenen Pusten und seit wann haben Sie diese trockenen Pusten?
Das habe ich auch schon lange, das nimmt man ja immer nicht so schwer. Ja, das habe ich schon eine ganze Weile.
Okay, ich muss diese Beschwerden wieder ein bisschen tiefgehen.
Und seit drei Bereistungen, Sie haben gesagt, rücken und sieben Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg.
Sie haben gesagt, stark intensiv ist ein bisschen wellen für mich, aber die Schmerzen auch...
Ja, also ich habe ja jetzt nicht seit drei Monaten immer ansteigende Schmerzen,
zwischen ruhig wird es ein bisschen weniger, aber...
Schmerzen immer bleiben, ja, immer bestehen.
Ganz weg gehen die gar nicht, ja.
Okay, genau, ja. Und leiden Sie unter Luftmord?
Ja, sagt ich ja, wenn ich treppen hoch laufe, dann kriege ich nicht gut Luft.
Okay. Das ist aber auch relativ neu, das habe ich früher nicht gehabt.
Genau.
Diese Bauchschmerzen auch, haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher gehabt?
Nee, solche Bauchschmerzen kenne ich nicht. Also klar, hat man mal Magenschmerzen oder so,
aber solche Schmerzen wie jetzt, nee, so, was habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sind Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden beim anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nee, ich bin da nicht hingegangen. Ich denke immer Hausart, der kennt mich sowieso nicht so gut.
Okay, haben Sie etwas eingenommen, Medikamente eingenommen, um diese Schmerzen zu linden?
Ja, ich habe versucht, Schnaps zu trinken, aber das war irgendwie auch nicht gut.
Okay. Welche haben Sie getrunken? Ich habe nicht verstanden eigentlich.
Ich habe Schnaps getrunken.
Schnaps, genau. Okay.
Ich meine, ich trink sowieso regelmäßig mal so ein Schnäpschen und dann habe ich versucht,
ob das damit besser wird, habe mich mal ein mehr getrunken, aber so richtig gut war das auch nicht.
Ja, leider nicht gehofft, aber wir werden alles tun, um Ihnen zu helfen in diesem Abteilung,
in diesem kranken Haus.
Und Sie haben gesagt, glaube ich, am Anfang, dass Sie ein bisschen Kribbeln in den Beinen aufgefangen haben.
Ja, ja, ja. Ja, und die Beine kribbeln und ich bin so ein bisschen unruhig auf. Das merke ich auch.
Nur in den Beinen, anderen Beinen haben Sie diese...
Das Kribbeln ist nur in den Beinen, ja.
Beide Beinen, ja?
Ja, ja, das ist gleich.
Genau, ja.
Und haben Sie angeschworene Beine bemerkt oder ist Ihnen aufgefallen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht gemessen.
Aber für Sie ist es nicht fieberig?
Aber fieberig? Manchmal steht es sich in der Nacht, ja.
Aber ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen. Ich denke, das ist wahrscheinlich kein Fieber, sondern das ist nur, weil es im Bett warm ist.
Okay, schwitzen Sie sich in der Nacht, ja?
Seit drei Monaten, oder?
Ja, vielleicht auch schon ein bisschen länger.
Und jetzt ist ja auch erst Sommer im Winter, habe ich nicht geschwitzt, aber jetzt schwitze ich.
Okay.
Und bleiben Sie unter Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen?
Schüttelfrost?
Also Herzrasen, das habe ich schon manchmal, ja.
Dass ich das Gefühl habe, das klopft ganz schnell.
Und das ist eigentlich so, wenn ich mich abends hinlege, dann merke ich das mit einem Mal, ja.
Ja, okay.
Müssen Sie mehrere Kissen benutzen, um gut zu schlafen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Erhöre auch mehr Köpper, ja?
Keine.
Wie ist die Appetit?
Zur Zeit schmeckt es mir nicht so gut.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zugenommen haben, ja?
Ja, deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich esse eigentlich wenig, weil es mir eigentlich gar nicht gut schmeckt.
Und trotzdem habe ich zugenommen.
Okay, wie viele Kilogramm in den letzten Monaten?
Haben Sie genommen?
Ja, das mögen so drei, vier Kilo gewesen sein.
Ja.
Sie waren 30 Kilogramm, haben Sie gesagt?
Und jetzt?
Ich habe 86 Kilo gewogen, oder ich wiege 86 Kilo und ich habe mal 89 gewogen, oder 90?
90.
Ach Quatsch, nee, umgekehrt, umgekehrt. Nein, also jetzt wiege ich 86 und ich habe immer 81 gewogen.
Ja, 81, genau, sieben Kilogramm haben Sie zugenommen.
Fünf Kilogramm, in den letzten drei Monaten, oder?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Ich wiege mich ja nicht so oft.
Ja, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Strugang?
Ja, manchmal habe ich ein bisschen Durchfall.
Aber mit dem Wasserlassen habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Hin und wieder habe ich mal so ein bisschen Durchfall und ich habe ziemlich viel Blähung zur Zeit.
Wie bitte?
Ich habe ziemlich viel Blähungen.
Ja, Blähungen, genau.
Sie fühlen sich, als ob sie Ballon ein bisschen, ja?
Ja, so ein bisschen, genau.
Ja, okay.
Füllige Füll haben Sie.
Und Blähungen auch haben Sie, ja, das, okay.
Müssen Sie Sauer aufstoßen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Sortbrennen haben Sie?
Nein, auch nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer krankgeschichte Fragen stellen.
Leider sind Sie an einer bestimmten chronischen Erkrankung,
von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel Blutzkorkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck.
Nein, ich gehe ja nicht so oft zum Arsch.
Also ich glaube, ich habe nix, so viel ich weiß.
Bisher war ich immer so weit gesund.
Das Einzige, was ich mal hatte, ich habe mir mal den Unterverschenkel,
da hatte ich mal ein Beinbruch und da bin ich operiert worden.
Aber sonst bin ich eigentlich nicht beim Arsch.
Okay, Beinbruch, wann haben Sie operiert wegen Beinbruch?
Ja, das ist jetzt, lassen Sie mich überlegen, das ist jetzt so 15 Jahre her.
Vor 15 Jahren.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie operiert und jetzt sind Sie beschwerdet frei, oder?
Ja, das ist alles gut verheilt, ja.
Okay.
Total Endoprotest?
Nein, nein, das war eine Fraktur im Unterschenkel.
Ha, ja, okay, okay, ein Fraktur.
Ansonsten keine weitere Operationen bei Ihnen, ja?
Nein, das bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente, regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, nehme ich wohl mal Aspirin ein oder so,
aber eigentlich nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, Aspirin, wie viele Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ach, was steht denn da drauf?
Das steht glaube ich, kann das sein, dass da 200 drauf steht?
Dann nehme ich dann mal zwei Stück, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe oder so.
Ja, das ist 200, oder?
Ich meine ja.
Wenn Sie Kopfschmerzen haben oder so, ja.
Sind Sie gegen etwas allergisch?
Glaube nicht, eigentlich habe ich keine Allergien.
Sind Ihnen Unverhältlichkeiten, irgendwelche Unverhältlichkeiten bekannt, aufgefallen?
Ich bisher war ich immer gesund, ich habe keine Allergien,
ich habe kann alles essen, kann alles trinken, war nicht beim Arzt.
Nur jetzt ist mir halt so furchtbar schlecht und habe ich diese Schmerzen.
Okay, ja.
Und lauchen Sie?
Ja, rauchen tue ich schon, ja.
Seit wann lauchen Sie?
Und wie viel Päckchen am Tag?
Na ja, so, zwei Päckchen am Tag sind es bestimmt.
Und ja, lassen Sie mich überlegen, vielleicht so, seit ich 18 bin oder so 19, da habe ich angefangen,
am Anfang habe ich nicht so viel geraucht, aber jetzt inzwischen brauche ich schon so zwei Päckchen am Tag.
Genau, ja, seit 18 bin, das heißt seit 28 Jahren.
28 Jahre lang rauchen Sie Zigarette und zwei Päckchen am Tag, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, klar, also ein paar Flaschen Bier am Tag und ja, manchmal eben auch ein Schnaps.
Wobei der Schnaps hat mir in den letzten Tagen nicht so gut geschmeckt.
Und bitte nehmen Sie diese nächste, meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine medisische Frage, ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Droge nehmen?
Drogen, nee, also Droge, Bier und Schnaps, das reicht, also Drogen nehme ich nicht auch.
Okay, wie ist ja Impfstatus?
Mein Impfstatus, also ich bin gegen Corona, wenn Sie das wissen wollen.
Ja, Sie sind gegen Corona vorständig, ja?
Da, da habe ich drei Impfungen.
Okay, gut.
Und andere Grundimpfungen haben Sie erhärten, oder?
Ja, so als Kind, was man da so bekommt und dann habe ich irgendwann mal eine Tetanusimpfung bekommen,
als ich mich verletzt habe, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht, was ich sonst für Impfungen bekommen habe.
Okay, sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Im Ausland, nee, da bin ich nicht gewesen.
Okay, keiner. Traiben Sie Sport oder jetzt können Sie gut Sport treiben?
Nein, also Sport war noch nie so mein Ding.
Ja, also bei der Arbeit ist es anstrengend genug, da brauche ich nicht noch Sport hinterher.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein, nein, nein, nur damals vor 15 Jahren, als ich mir das Bein gebrauchen habe.
Aber jetzt in letzter Zeit hatte ich keinen Unfall, nein.
Okay, ja, gut.
Jetzt möchte ich zu Ihrer Familiengeschichte etwas fragen.
Jetzt sind Sie verheiratet oder wie ist Ihre Familienstatus?
Ich bin geschieden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ja, aber die leben bei meiner Frau.
Okay, und leben Sie allein oder?
Ich lebe alleine, ja.
Okay.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Zwei Kinder.
Wie gesund sind Sie?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Und ich vermute, dass Ihr Eltern auch noch leben, oder?
Ja, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Aber mein Vater, der ist noch nicht so lange her.
Der ist auch nicht alt geworden, der ist Mitte 70, ist sehr gestorben.
Okay, woran ist er gestorben?
Ja, der hatte Demenz und der hatte dann auch Probleme mit der Leber.
Okay.
Und gestorben, ja.
Mutter lebt noch und hat die Mutter etwas...
Ja, meine Mutter, die hat ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck,
das hat sie immer erzählt und ich weiß auch, dass die Diabetes hat.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe ein Typ zwei, oder?
Ja, also ich habe das jetzt erst im Alter gekommen, ja.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es Ihnen Ihre Familiengeschichte, wichtige chronische Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel Ihre grossen Eltern, oder so?
Nee, sonst ist ich nicht, dass da irgendwas war,
dass ja auch alles schon so lange her, da weiß ich aber nichts zu machen.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie als Berufrich?
Ich arbeite im Straßenbau.
Straßenbau?
Ja, sind Sie damit zufrieden bei der Arbeit?
Ja, das ist halt anstrengend, aber wird gut bezahlt.
Ja, okay.
Ja, Herr Schlütten, ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde noch stellen an sich stellen.
Sie haben gesagt, oder ich möchte kurz das Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit drei Monaten Oberbauchschmerzen haben
und die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten und im Laufe derzeit schlimmer geworden.
Und die Schmerzen sind drückend und dunter und bewegungsabhängig
und Sie können nicht gut bewegen oder Sie können nicht gut laufen oder Treppen steigen.
Ja, da habe ich aber nicht, das ist nicht so sehr mit den Schmerzen,
sondern das ist mehr, dass ich dann so keine Luft mehr kriege.
Genau, Luft mehr kriege, ja, kriege und Sie haben auch trockene Husten.
Seit wann haben Sie diese trockene Husten?
Ach, den habe ich schon lange, wissen Sie als Raucher,
da wundert man sich ja eigentlich nicht, wenn man so ein bisschen hustet.
Genau, ja.
Okay. Und wegen dieser trockene Husten, auch Sie, Sie waren beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, der sagt ja nur, ich soll aufhören mit Rauchen, das will ich ja gar nicht hören.
Okay, ja.
Ja, möchten Sie etwas hinstellen?
Oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Sie haben mir jetzt schon so viele Fragen gestellt und ich habe schon so viel erzählt.
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich, was kann man tun, dass es mir wieder besser geht,
dass ich wieder arbeiten kann und dass ich mir nicht so schlapp fühle.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Ich möchte noch eine Frage auch an sich stellen.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt, das habe ich ja gesagt, dass mir immer so schlecht ist, ja.
Genau, und haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, so ein, zwei Mal, ja, aber da habe ich, wenn man viel Alkohol trinkt,
dann passiert das schon mal, dass man sich übergeben muss, ne?
Ja, ist das verbinden mit diesen Bauchschmerzen?
Also ich weiß nicht, ich glaube nicht so richtig.
Okay.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie erbrochen?
Sie haben jetzt zwei Mal oder dreimal?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit, zweimal, ja.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen erklären, wie wir vorgehen können.
Herr Schnüttel, zuerst möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Sie haben hoosten, trockene Hoosten und auch Sie haben Bauchschmerzen.
Ich möchte beide auch körperlich untersuchen und von ihnen Blut abnehmen
und Bauchultraschall würde ich durchführen und würde gern zwei Ebenen,
die Brustkorb würde ich veranlassen.
Und für EKG möchte ich schreiben.
Und auch mit diesen Ergebnissen und mit diesem Befinden werde ich mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich zu Ihnen kommen und sage Ihnen, wie wir vorgehen können.
Okay.
Ja, dann warte ich so lange jetzt.
Ja, weiter untersuchen und behandeln müssen Sie sich aber untersuchen.
Okay.
Ja, danke schön.
Ja, okay.
Kollegen haben Fragen, eine Frage, haben Sie Geldverwaltung in der Haut oder in Ihren Augen?
Also hat er nicht bemerkt?
Sind nicht mehr so irgendwelche Organe austrachen?
Also beschreibt der Patient nicht, der hat nur die Fuse, eigentlich die Fuse Oberbauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie ein Engigechil in der Brust?
Nein, also er beschreibt, er beschreibt, dass er Luft nötig ist bei Belastung, aber er, das wird nicht explizit als Engige Gefühl in der Brust beschrieben,
aber er beschreibt schon auch, dass er zwischendurch Herzrasen hat, dass er das merkt, dass das Herz schneller klopft.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Bitte?
Seit wann trinken Sie Alkohol?
Boah, schon ewig. Ja, seit der Erwachsenen ist Tränkler.
Sind die Echse beinahe krippen auch in Ruhe oder nur bei Belastung?
Gerade in Ruhe.
Okay.
Und unsere Kollegin Ali ist da. Ali?
Ali? Ja? Ali? Super.
Hallo. Hallo.
Guten Abend Frau Wichmann. Wie geht es Ihnen?
Ja, wie geht es Ihnen?
Ja, natürlich. Super. Ich habe...
Entschuldigung, jetzt, ja, ich habe eine Anrufe bekommen. Ich habe schon bestanden heute. Zum Glück.
Ja, super. Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Ja, super. Danke sehr.
Und aber jetzt, ich, leider, ich kann nicht Sie hören. Hallo.
Ah, super. Super. Jetzt, jetzt, ich kann hören.
Ja, die Prüfung dauerte ungefähr vier Stunden.
Und es war sehr schwer eigentlich für mich, weil Prüfer wollten nicht...
eigentlich nicht nur eine annahmen Gespräche führen, sondern sehr viele Reaktionen zu machen
und eigentlich, es gibt viele verschiedene umgangssprachliche Symptome.
Deswegen konnte ich leider nicht ganz genau verstehen, aber immer, aber immer, ich habe nachgefragt.
Super.
Ja, die Patientin hat gesagt, ja, heute, einen Moment, ja, einen Moment bitte.
Ein Moment.
Sie haben mir gesagt, eigentlich jetzt, ich habe noch nicht verstanden.
Sie hat immer ihre Gürtel gezeigt und ja, Sie haben schon gesehen, aber es gab einen Verb.
Ich habe niemals verstanden und ich habe gefragt, was meinen Sie, das bedeutet, Sie haben viel kilo abgenommen oder zugenommen
und die Patientin hat immer gesagt, Herr Doktor, immer habe ich gesagt, ich habe gleiche Sache gesagt
und dann, aber leider, ich konnte nicht verstehen.
Und am Ende der Prüfung, der Prüfer hat mir gesagt, Herr Doktor, Sie mussten viele umgangssprachliche Sachen wissen.
Sie konnten sehr gut Hochdeutsch sprechen oder Ihre medizinische Kenntnis war sehr gut, aber Sie mussten ein bisschen umgangssprachliche lernen oder so.
Und eigentlich, ich weiß es nicht, welche Buch gibt es diese Informationen oder ich weiß es nicht eigentlich.
Da fällt mir eigentlich jetzt auch nichts dazu ein, wo man jetzt so spontan sagen würde, was die jetzt gemeint hat.
Und meine, wenn da jemand am Gürtel handiert, dann würde ich schon auch fragen, haben Sie zu oder abgenommen, das ist das Einzige, was einem dazu eintält.
Ja, und also, dann muss die halt in Gott's Namen eine andere Formulierung wählen, wenn Sie eine mit keinem Mittel der Welt verstehen.
Aber Sie sagten, da wären mehrere solche Sachen?
Eigentlich zwei oder dreimal, ja, hat sie gemacht und ja, manchmal leider ich...
Hat sie den Dialekt gesprochen?
Nein, nicht Dialekt.
Aber manche umgangssprachliche Verben hat sie immer benutzt.
Ja gut, das versuche ich ja hin und wieder auch.
Der hier heute hat ja auch jetzt nicht so richtig, der hat ja auch nicht so richtig fachlich richtig gesprochen, sondern hat ja auch sich so ein bisschen drum herum geredet.
Ja, und das erleben Sie natürlich schon immer wieder, aber man musste sich ja nun in der Prüfung nicht bis zum Exzest betreiben.
Aber was war denn jetzt eigentlich die tatsächliche Diagnose oder was war denn die Grunderkrankung von der Patientin?
Es war Diabetes mellitus, aber nicht ganz genau oder nicht ganz klar.
Immer, ja, am Anfang, eine Mitarbeiter hat uns gesagt, sie müssen nicht eine Verdrachtdiagnose, ja, wissen oder feststellen, weil alle Fälle ist sehr kompliziert.
Und deswegen nur, ja, zum Beispiel, mein Fall war auch wie Herzinsuffizienz oder Diabetesincipitus, der gleiche manchmal zum Beispiel bei Diabetes mellitus manchmal brennende Fuß könnte Patient haben oder andere zum Beispiel trockenen Mund oder Polydipsy und so weiter.
Ja, Polydipsy, aber ich meine Diabetesincipitus ist ja schon sehr exotisch eigentlich.
Ja, ich habe als Differenzialdiagnose viele unterschiedliche Diagnose gesagt und ja, eigentlich...
Ja, helfen Sie aber, irgendwie haben wir gerade gefragt, wo Sie Ihre Prüfung gemacht haben?
In Frankfurt.
Also sehen Sie sich vor in Frankfurt, das ist ja die Hölle.
Ja, ja, sehr gut.
Aber nach vier Stunden hatten Sie Ihr Päckchen gepackt und dann war es okay.
Ja, nach der Prüfung haben Sie gemeint, eigentlich, ich habe nicht ganz verstanden.
Also nach den vier Stunden wussten Sie aber Bescheid, jetzt ist es ja auch.
Ja, natürlich, zum Glück.
Ja, ich hatte ein bisschen Chance und Gott sei Dank, ja, ich habe in meinem Heimatland 2,5 Jahre als Assistenzarzt im Bereich innerer Medizin gearbeitet.
Ja, Diabetesincipitus, ja, ich habe viele Erfahrungen und ich habe viele Informationen über Diabetesincipitus gegeben.
Deswegen, ja, Prüfa war sehr...
Ja, genau, sehr zufrieden.
Und normalerweise habe ich schon einen Arbeitsvertrag erhalten von einer Rehabilitation Klinik.
Genau, und sie habe mir gesagt, nein, deine Kenntnisse ist sehr gut und du musst unbedingt eine Akut Klinik arbeiten.
Aber leider, Sprachbarriere ist immer schwer und deswegen habe ich erklärt, warum ich zuerst in Deutschland eine Rehabilitation Klinik arbeiten möchte.
Aber zum Glück, nach vier Stunden habe ich diese Prüfung gekauft.
Na ja, na gut, ja.
Okay, dann kann ich nur sagen, ruhen Sie sich aus auf Ihren Lorbeeren und freuen Sie sich, dass es gut geklappt hat.
So richtig bedenken hatte ich zu keinem Zeitpunkt.
Okay, sehr schön.
Aber...
Ja, würde ich etwas sagen, Frau Weichmann, ja, ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen für alles.
Normalerweise habe ich immer gesehen und gehört, dass Ausländische Arzt immer eine Sprachpartner für Anamnesgespräch sucht.
Aber manchmal kann man nur ausländische Menschen finden.
Und Sie oder Herr Haiko gibt es noch eine Muttersprache, er spricht Muttersprache und Sie auch.
Ja, das ist sehr hilfreich, das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Ja, tausend Dank für alles.
Ja, gerne. Ja, ich freue mich, wenn es dann klappt. Wunderbar.
Ja, gut, jetzt wollen wir den Armdoktor in ihn, aber nicht noch länger hier auf die Polter spannen.
Der will jetzt ja seinen Fall gerne schildern.
Aber schön Dank für die Prüfungsschilderung, das war bestimmt für alle auch so etwas, dass Sie denken, oh Mann, hoffentlich passiert mir sowas nicht, oder?
4 Stunden ist schon wirklich hardcore.
Okay, freuen Sie sich und alles Gute für die Zukunft.
Vielen Dank, vielen Dank für alles, tausend Dank.
Ja, gerne.
Ich freue mich, Sie auch gerne zu lernen.
Ja, gleichfalls.
So, jetzt, lieber Doktor, los gehts.
Ja, ich noch habe eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie schnappst immer trinken.
Und wie viel Glase am Tag?
Oder wie viel?
Das steht hier nicht so genau.
Aber ich würde mal tippen, der trinkt schon ein paar Schnetze am Tag.
Wie?
Der trinkt schon ein paar Schnetze am Tag.
Und Gut Bier, ne?
Ja.
Okay, Frau Obererstin, hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Herr Udo Schluter.
Ich habe einen 640 Jahre alt und 86 Kilogramm schwer und 1,80 Meter groß.
Herr Udo Schluter hat sich bei uns seit drei Monaten bestehender Oberbauchschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten und seien im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien drückend und dunkler.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10 bei 5.
Die Schmerzen seien bewegungsabhängig.
Der Patient könne nicht gut bewegen oder wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Und auch belastungsabhängig, auch mit begleiteten Husten.
Der Patient hat viel Schnaps getrunken, um diese Schmerzen zu linden.
Aber der Schnaps hat nichts geholfen.
Und keine Ausstrahlung.
Und es gebe keinen bestimmten Auslöse für diese Schmerzen.
Und aus Begleitzentren habe der Patient seit mehreren Monaten trocken auf Husten.
Weil er seit 28 Jahren 2 Päckchen Cigarette am Tag lauchert.
Und der Patient habe Kribbel an den Beinen bemerkt.
Nur an den Beinen.
Und Ödemä und Hautverterbuck an den Beinen wurden vermeint.
Neben diesem Husten habe der Patient auch,
oder leider der Patient auch unter Atemnode und Herzrasen.
Und der Patient leider unter Inapetens.
Und eine Gewitzsunahme, 5 Kilogramm in den letzten 3 Monaten.
Und der Patient auch leider unter Durchfall und Meteorismus.
Die Oral-Metrorismus.
Übel und zweimal Erbrochen habe der Patient auch außerhalb.
Die Regalteranase sei unabhängig bis auf genannten Symptomen.
Die Vorgeschichte, er gab eine Beinbruchoperation.
Vor 15 Jahren.
Und der Patient nehme wegen des nicht regelmäßen Beibedarf Aspirin,
200 Milligramm bei Aspirin ein.
Und Unvertätigkeit und Allergie wurden vermeint bei dieser Patient.
Und Herr Undurschlüttel, wie ich gesagt habe,
rauch er seit 28 Jahren, 2 Pechchenamtag.
Und das heißt, 56 Pechcheniers.
Und Trinke, Schnaps und ein paar Schnapsamtag und Bier.
Und Drogen wurden vermeint.
Und der Patient war vollständig geimpft.
Und die Reise und Unfall sei unabhängig.
Oder wurden vermeint.
Der Patient sei geschieden, habe 2 Kinder und lebe alleine.
Der Patient lebe alleine.
Und der Mutter von den Patienten lebe noch.
Leider an einer Arterielehypertonie und Typ 2 Diabetes Militär.
Und der Vater des Patienten sei gestorben.
Und habe hatte Demers und Leber Erkrankungen.
Ist denn dieser Patient mal beim Arzt gewesen vorher?
Nein, die Fragen nach Englische Beschwerden
und der Frage nach Anwesinheit in anderem Arzt,
wurden vermeint.
Und der Patient sei Straßenbauer von Beruf
und sei zufrieden bei der Arbeit.
Die Analympic Angaben deuten am ersten auf eine Kollestitis hin.
Die Alternativen kommen folgendes.
Und auch Hepatitis.
Und zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich den Patienten
zuerst eine Köpelschung der Suche.
Und dann habe ich die Analympic Analympic.
Und zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich den Patienten zuerst
eine Köpelschung der Suche durch.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, zuerst Bauch möchte ich abklopfen.
Natürlich zuerst Abhören und Abklopfen.
Der Bereich würde ich abtasten und natürlich palpieren.
Und auch die Lunge und das Herz würde ich abhören.
Mit dem Stiftepfiff.
Und Bauch würde ich mit dem Ultraschall.
Was erwarten Sie denn da?
Bauch Ultraschall würde eigentlich erwarte ich eine Lebervergrößerung.
Und vielleicht gar den Gang Verrängung.
Und auch Stein kann ich dort anschauen.
Und auch die anderen Nieren, Milzt und Organen würde ich anschauen.
Und Beurteilung mit Ultraschall Sonografie.
Und EKG würde ich schreiben.
Und auch eine Röntgen-Torax, zwei Ebenen Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Und was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Mit dem Labor.
Ja, mit dem Labor würde ich, kolestaswerte, würde ich anschauen.
Und Beurteilung z.B. gegen Tee und Gallen oder GLP auch.
CRP würde ich anschauen.
Und Blutbild würde ich anschauen.
Hemoglobin und andere Entzündungswerte.
Und Nierenwerte, Leberwerte natürlich.
Ja, Alethaseth z.B.
Ja, Adeline.
Gut.
Und gegen den Fass eine Komputer-Torografie für Bauch.
Bauch, Komputer-Torografie, kann ich auch, könnte ich auch veranlassen.
Gegen den Fass.
Okay.
Gut, ja, dann, was wäre denn Ihr Therapievorschlag?
Ja, sollte sich meine Verrückung sehr bestätigen, würde ich zuerst Zugang legen.
Dann, dann pass ich an, nach Ruscarren würde ich empfehlen, bis wir eine Diagnose festgestellt haben.
Und Schmerzmittel geben und gegen den Fass eine Antibiotika-Aprilbreiche.
Auch Stationale aufnehmen, zuerst natürlich.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ja, und Schmerzmittel.
Ja, Schmerzmittel und für die Luftnot würde ich auch Sauerstoff-Setigung anschauen.
Mit Blutkart, Blüter, ja.
Mit dieser Sauerstoff-Setigung kann ich auch eine Sauerstoff anlegen.
Ah ja, okay.
Gut.
Okay, dann untersuchen Sie mal den Patienten und halten mich auf dem laufenden, was bei dem rausgekommen ist, ja?
Ja.
Ja, eine Sache, eine Sache, bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, haben Sie, glaube ich, der Ärztin jetzt nicht erzählt?
Und zwar, Sie haben, glaube ich, nicht von der Zunahme des Bauchumfangs berichtet.
Ja, genau, ja.
Und das würde natürlich wiederum eine diagnostische Maßnahme, wonach gucken Sie beim Ultraschall?
Ja, diese Assite, diese freie Musikkeit im Bauch würde ich anschauen.
Also, der hat ja eine große Wahrscheinlichkeit, hat der Assitis, wenn er also Akku zugenommen hat und das also alles im Bauch sitzt.
Genau.
Und in der Fallbeschreibung ist es tatsächlich eine Leberzerose.
Leberzerose, genau, ja.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich eine Leberzerose.
Und, was natürlich so ein bisschen die Stur legt, ist der hochgradige und langjährige Alkoholkonsum.
Und, ja, potentiell, also wenn man dann so Familiengeschichte anguckt, im Sinne von Lebensgewohnheiten,
die Geschichte, dass der Vater eben auch eine Leberkrankheit verstorben ist, da kann man ja vermuten,
dass es da so eine gewisse Rückkoppelung gegeben hat, was weiß ich, dass der sich das Verhalten, das Trinkverhalten vom Vater abgeguckt hat, ja.
Also, Fakt ist, in dem Fallbeispiel ist es tatsächlich die Leberzerose gewesen.
Ja.
Und da war als Differenzialdiagnosen, war da, genau wie Sie gesagt haben, die Hepatitis mit drin, es war noch miterwähnt,
ein Leber und ein Magenkartzinom.
Ah, da kommt es, ja, genau.
Wäre ja auch nicht so ganz von der Welt, ja.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, Sprachen, ich fand es ziemlich gut.
Ich musste nur am Anfang ein bisschen lachen, ich habe mir das gleich auch geschrieben.
Sie haben gefragt, wie viel groß sind Sie und wie viel schwer sind Sie?
Ja.
Wie viel wiegen Sie oder wie schwer sind Sie?
Und wie groß sind Sie oder wie viele Zentimeter sind Sie groß, ja.
Wie viel schwer und wie viel groß?
Genau.
Wie groß sind Sie, wie schwer sind Sie?
Und ansonsten fand ich sprachlich jetzt okay, vielleicht ein bisschen, ein bisschen besser sortieren noch in dem Fragebereich,
die verschiedenen Kategorien.
Ja.
Und ich habe mich noch mal auf die Schmerzen zurückgekommen, wobei das für mich tatsächlich immer das Schwierigste ist zu beschreiben.
Ich beschreibe ja Schmerzen, die ich selber tatsächlich nicht habe.
Ja.
Und ich muss mich also immer auf das verlassen, was ich hier schwarz auf weiß beschrieben habe.
Und ich bin natürlich kein Arzt, ja.
Ich habe nicht schon 50 Leute mit Leberzehrose kennengelernt, ja.
Und ich weiß jetzt wirklich nicht, wie sich das Beschwerdebild zeigt, ja.
Ich muss mich dann immer so ein bisschen rumdrücken und da sind auch vielleicht die Angaben nicht immer so ganz konkret, ja.
Und der hat ja eigentlich am Anfang schon eine Menge von so Nebensymptomen gesagt, ja.
Der hatte ja eigentlich, hatte er zwar Bauchschmerzen, ist deshalb gekommen, aber eigentlich hat er ja gesagt,
Boah, ich fühle mich so schlecht und bin so schlapp und mir ist immer übel und so.
Der hat ja schon ein ganzes Paket eigentlich mitgeliefert an Infos, ja.
Und das muss man dann halt noch mal so ein bisschen auflösen und noch mal sagen, sie haben erwähnt
und dass man das dann noch mal so in Stichpunkten hat, ne.
Und ja, und ja, was ich immer den Klassiker finde, sind sie nicht der Erste.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig, bis auf.
Und dann kommt Durchfall, Schweiß, Nachtschweiß, Inappetenz und Tropenlahusten.
Damit ist die vegetative Anamnese schlichtweg nicht mehr unauffällig, ja.
Sondern da ist sie auffällig.
Genau, ja.
Also da muss man halt anders formulieren, muss man bei der vegetativen Anamnese ergab sich, bang, bang, bang, bang.
Und dann muss man die Punkte sagen.
Unauffällig ist das jedenfalls nicht mehr mit vier Punkten.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ansonsten, wie gesagt, alles gut verständlich und ich glaube auch von ihrer Seite alles gut verstanden.
Und die, ich meine auch alles, alles gut, gut übergebracht.
Nur die Acidis haben sie, haben sie der Oberärztin verschrieben.
Ja.
Deswegen habe ich dann auch da nicht nachgefragt, sonst hätte ich nämlich schon gefragt, was erwarten Sie beim Ultraschall im Bauch?
Und da haben Sie das halt nicht gesagt.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Das ist eine gute Formulierung.
Gut.